bro
really all right hey what's going on
everybody it's Bill Burr and it's time
for the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday Morning podcast and I'm
just checking in on you and as you can
see it's video which means I have a
definitely a special guest
this is the only time I do these is if
the guest is special
I don't mean mentally challenged the way
that used to me right back in the day
that meant special I don't mean special
like that I mean a special mind who
wrote an incredible new book that is
going to be out on May 16th called
Harold I actually read the whole thing I
feel like I should have a sticker on my
forehead the legendary Steven Wright
everybody thank you how are you let me
get you in towards the microphone here
there we go I'm good how are you I'm
good that amplifies the sound really and
gets you out to the uh I never heard of
such a thing thanks for having me I
appreciate it I appreciate you coming
out
um to the podcast and I have to tell you
this might come as a shocker I'm not a
big reader you know I'm a big Watcher or
somebody tells me something happens and
I just go like all right that's easier
than fact checking I'll just agree with
you I sat down I brought this uh I was
flying to Ottawa
and I started reading it waiting for my
plane and I did not put it down until I
landed and I loved it so much really I
actually started slowing down because I
didn't want it to end like I don't know
if you ever finished like a video game
and you there's like that depression
that you can't go out and kill any more
zombies
um I got that feeling in a literary way
this book is called Harold it's about
uh a kid in the 1960s in third grade and
the whole book takes place one day
of his year as a third grader and
um I I can't I can't even tell you I
can't wait first of all it's a fact that
you couldn't stop reading it is like
that's an incredible compliment you know
I mean people it's just only a few
people were involved who who worked you
know the editor and stuff already you're
like the first person I couldn't put it
that can I can I read anything that's in
here sure it opened right up to this
because I actually have read this so
many times he remembered his grandfather
telling him that that there is no time
and time is moving slow and fast all at
once the kid is is he has a real close
relationship with his grandfather so he
sort of Daydream a lot slash add during
his entire day at school
um time is moving slow and fast all at
once he continued and the grandfather
says a snail is taking tiny tiny steps
on the armrest of his seat a seat that's
on a 747 crew speed 580 miles an hour or
the Concord crew speed 1 356 miles per
hour that's your life you're a snail on
a jet he said some people don't respect
the little time they have and waste it a
lot of it throwing that time into a wood
chipper they also destroy other people's
time by being upset over meaningful
Harold's mother did
this all the time and it's just like I I
had to set the book down when I read
that really because I was like first of
all the idea of the the two types of
time like how long it's taking the snail
to go across the armrest while that
thing
you know which I think is a metaphor for
being on the earth flying through space
and then what killed me there was
people wasting other people's time
bitching about meaningful meaningless
I'm just like oh my God that's
me how much of my wife's time have I
wasted going like this goddamn
guy said he was going to be there at six
and he gets there at 6 30 like
nothing's wrong you know just an idiot
so like I really
like and and the people that have wasted
my time but I I kind of saw I was like
wow I'm sort of on both sides
of the coin there but like I really felt
like this is the first book I've read
since you know the one that everybody
had to read grown up Catcher in the Rye
this is like Catcher in the Rye uh on
mushrooms is the only way for me to
describe it but I actually like this
character where I didn't like the
character oh yeah right because he was
kind of a hipster douche like when he
like when he went when he went to go see
that he went he snuck out he goes down
to the village and he goes to see that
piano player right and he says uh
he goes look and the guy was real he was
great at piano and he goes but he knew
he was great oh so that ruined it and
it's just like no he was great at it he
was confident and you knew he was going
to get a bunch of after it and you
weren't so that bothered you and rather
you trying to tap into your own Burt
Reynolds you're gonna resent this guy
and it also tapped into like
yeah and I feel like the beginning of
like that sort of hipsters nerds taking
over where they tore down the idea of
what a guy's guy was you know which
needed to be lampooned after all of the
action movies and of the 80s it did
need to be Lampoon but they did it to
such a level that they acted
like that guy didn't even exist and it's
like no that guy did exist there was did
like everybody went to high school
with some kid that was crushing it in
sports or something it was literally all
was getting Celebrity level yeah
they're the famous people in the school
yeah and they were that they didn't have
to like you know go on stage and do a
dance or whatever they just were that
guy and we all like when I was a kid you
didn't make fun of that guy you looked
up to that guy going I wish I was
that guy I wish I had that guy's gift to
gab and everything and that that was the
thing that you know and I also think
that the movie stars that I grew up with
um The Charles Bronson's uh uh the
clints the McQueen's and all of those
guys
were um Lee Marvin I mean I loved lemur
yeah I mean that guy actually you know
he fought in Korea I believe everyone
but like three people in the Splatoon
died so when this guy was in a movie
with a gun going I'm gonna kill
you like he had actually done that
so like
that was my idea the guy's guy and I
feel like they they started making fun
of like the the action heroes of the 80s
and they went all the way back to like
Lee Marvel's like this these guys are
like war heroes so anyway what I
like about this kid
is um I like that he had you know he's a
crush on the girl Elizabeth I believe
his name is and he's afraid to talk to
her and he and and so much of it is like
add and you have like your world view in
it like did this book like is like when
you talk about the time how it's it's
going fast and slow it's going
frontwards backwards and sideways this
book like is doing the same thing wow I
feel like
it's like he's in the class but he's
mentally he goes on these add trips he
comes back and then there's all of this
you know that that uh beginning of a
comedian we have all this funny
that you want to say but you don't have
the balls to say yeah to the teacher yep
and the pretty girls can't see you yeah
yeah because you are whatever your
beautiful peacock tale is all in here
where like the kid out on the field you
know tossing the football is is just
there's a no-brainer that that's the guy
that they should go bang instead of you
or whatever there's just so much
of that uh in here and I was wondering
like
you know how long did it I read the
forward and everything it seems like you
you started to write this a long time
ago and it gradually came together yeah
it took about seven years
[Laughter]
I just I'm not sure I I think that's
funny too but I don't why no because
because you are this book dude you you
and I are are in the same
we're living on the planet at the same
time all right I'm going I'm on the 747
and you're the snail you're just like oh
you know what that took seven years and
like how like and like how I feel like I
was joking like I feel like I'm in The
Matrix and I'm just and I just react to
everything where you're outside the
Matrix looking at it with like like I
said to my wife like three times while I
was reading this book going like this
guy is operating on such a higher mental
plane than I could ever even hope to get
to and like I love how you live your
life because I I like how
um
what you do is one of the greatest
stand-up comedians of all time and you
have earned that too you have earned
that thank you and um
but what you do is so public
but you are so private and quiet and I
found that the longer I've been in this
business and and the bigger things get
the balance is is then I just keep
having like this this reoccurring
fantasy of being in the middle of
nowhere and I'm just not even I'm not
even on my front porch because I don't
want to see somebody drive by I am on my
back porch and I am just sitting
there
it's funny I'm enjoying myself and I'm
slowly killing myself like my wife isn't
there my kids aren't there I'm smoking
I'm drinking I'm taking drugs and I'm
and but I'm also simultaneously enjoying
nature yes and I'm just sort of shutting
the whole thing down and like I love
like like you know everybody back East
it's either you go to Nantucket or you
go to Martha's Vineyard no one goes to
Block Island right and you're like oh
what's up with this block I want to go
where nobody's going so I wanted I was
wondering like how did that uh is that
something that like because I mean you
had like this meteoric
rise those legendary Tonight Show
appearances
um
just to give people the quick backstory
that this was Ben hash over a zillion
times The Tonight Show people came out
to the Deng ho the first like real like
official beginning of the the Boston
comedy scene that all you guys started
and they went down there to see you know
gab Sweeney Lenny and all of those guys
and then you went up and that you ended
up being the guy they picked and you get
plucked out of this Chinese restaurant
to go on The Tonight Show that got like
a 30 share like they had 30 million
people watching it you go out you
absolutely destroy he he ends up talking
to you on panel you handle all of that
you blow up you make the short film you
win a freaking Oscar
and then it's just like you just went
into like The Ether and then then you'd
come back and you'd be like Reservoir
Dogs you're doing the DJ voice
and then you just like your ability to
like disappear and then come back and it
never dips you you like your ticket
sales don't go down it's just people
have accepted that this guy is gonna be
like he's gonna he's gonna drop a bomb
every seven years on us and it's gonna
blow our minds Jesus yeah it's amazing
you like the shade of stand-up comedians
she comes out with an album like every
eight years and it's still never been in
a sentence thank you no the Beast
this rock is good
is good and right was just right as you
think what what the is Chris Rock
doing bam he made a movie
like no plan though none of this was
planned like I mean you know going on
The Tonight Show and everything
happening everything but then I would
just write and and do the specials and
everything but I didn't I never looked
at a like okay I'll do this here then
I'll do this here right you know it was
all just like oh okay
was all very um
fun I never felt like like a big
pressure picturing you in like a meeting
after you destroyed and they all the
Hollywood guy's gone I'm gonna do this
and you're gonna sitcom you'll be as big
as coffee online you're kind of like all
right
like you exist on like your uh own time
is as I think that's what I'm trying to
say what I I
I really find the most uh you know aside
from just being such a huge fan of your
work is I really Envy like there's a
strength to that wow
um where uh you just feel like you know
you know I finally took like three
months off and I and I loved it yeah and
but I was there was that thing kind of
non at me going like after 90 days are
they gonna forget about me his 31 years
of of slamming my head against the Rocks
down the drain you like
um but then what I do is I always think
of guys
you know like you and everybody that I
just mentioned that that that do take
the time off and they come back and
there's like a uh I mean I mean dude you
just this deep well so the the quality
just keeps coming and um
so I don't know I think that when you're
saying go in and out I think you have to
uh take care of yourself you know you're
giving so much from your mind out to the
audience the audience is very at least
for me it's a very intense thing I might
look it looks like it looks like I'm
walking around just
but it's intense it's not a normal place
it's a stage it's very very intense and
that intensity it drain is draining to
you especially if you're a complete and
total introvert who shouldn't even be I
shouldn't even I'm really good at
something I shouldn't even be doing it's
against my are you an introvert person
oh 100 but I was talking to Michael
O'Brien he was telling me how like a
loner guy you are like I'm a major loner
and I just think that you're gushing out
of your all this stuff your imagination
out to the audience it's so extreme
and then you gotta like
Replenish by being away from it what do
you think that like I actually had the
thought today
about being a loner
and I was thinking I was like is that a
way that you're wired before you even
come out or if you have experienced
enough trauma
as a kid because I feel a lot of my
loner stuff became like hey you know
what the the advantage of being all by
yourself
no one can hurt me no one can with
me the ends and I can actually
let all put all defense things down and
I can just sit here and and you know
what's funny is I would do a lot of this
Herald where I would like I lived
most of my life in fantasy wow really
yes and the a lot of the fantasies
became uh real where uh I I fantasize
about doing stand-up I fantasized about
you know acting and you know making the
camera crew laugh and stuff and I
remember
uh when I was doing
um I did this sketch show and we were
doing one of these remote shoots
and I was just riffing and blah blah
blah and the whole time I was thinking
like all right you know there's that
annoying like oh my God just don't get
fired off of this gig and when we were
done shooting and everybody came up to
me I remember walking away thinking like
oh that was that thing
that I used to fantasize I wish I could
do that that just happened but the
fantasies don't just stop there I have
like defeated Isis I have solved World
Peace I've been the front man to every
major rock band in my head I know how to
rap I mean it just it I'm an astronaut
I'm a Navy SEAL like it never is
but that all relates to I think
self-loathing on some level of like like
you don't you just you know what I mean
like you just don't think you're good
enough you don't think like it's like
maybe if I was uh if I defeated
terrorism yeah if Jesus was my best
friend yeah
I mean he did get a hooker so I think I
could hang out with him but if he was
just 100 a good guy I would just be like
the entire time you just be reminded
what a piece of you are and be like
listen Jesus it's not you it's me I
can't I can't be I can't be around you
unbelievable well yeah I think a lot I
think to me I don't know are you born as
a loner or do you become a loner I I
think it's a maybe a combination I think
even being a loner I think is the
opposite of when you're on the stage and
it's so intense that you're giving out
but when you're growing up you're
bombarded by what all this what is this
the school your parents all this you
bombarded so much that I think as a
safety you release to how I see you're
driven deep into your own mind is that's
your area my area my privacy you know
growing up is my inside of my head
because the world
be pushed me there you know and then
you're in deep I don't know why this is
just how did you like how did you relate
when you were a kid how did you relate
to the world we you don't seem to me
like hey I'll collect baseball cards
like everybody else and get like a
Mickey Mouse I know you're a big
baseball fan but like you seem like were
you always a little left or a little
right of what I was very Norman
rockwellish grown up in Burlington Mass
Little League I had some baseball cards
everything everything was was uh
was really normal where I was what I was
doing uh
speaking of those kids who were famous
in the school of athletes who were the
stars you know they were my school in
Burlington there was a long car to and
then there was another one going
perpendicular so it was a tea it was a t
and in between classes when the bell
would go off those big famous guys would
stand right at the end like this so cool
you know and you had to go by there
maybe if your class was down here or
down here and I slowly developed I was
so nervous to walk by them that I
eventually started saying weird
saying funny stuff to them to make them
laugh and I didn't know it still
thinking back on it but I was defusing
the tension by making these giant people
laugh you know and I think that was a
beginning of of comedy in a way as a as
a defense but uh when you like I just
think you you're in you you're deep in
your head I I didn't you're probably
asking me when did I see that it wasn't
actually completely normal like what was
this or or that you you're uh
I don't know what it is it like at some
point like I think I was always secretly
kind of like that because I gravitated
towards any sort of rebellion any sort
of Class Clown
like if I had a job I didn't want to
work in the carpeted cubicle area where
everybody just seemed like they were
like the goody goodies I wanted to work
out in the warehouse where if people
were having like fun and and it's there
was a freedom to it and there was also a
uh
I don't I don't know what how to put it
like you weren't trying to get a
cubicle like he didn't give a like
it's like I'm doing this job because I
need beer money and I want I want to get
like tickets to the patch or something
like that and everybody out there either
played in a band or was a lot of
creative people out there or were like
drug addicts and and I just would I
don't know I always wanted to hang out
with them more so than some guy with the
shirt and tag you know talking about the
whatever the uh those people
talked about all right what's up
everybody it's time for Simply Safe and
immediately you should be like Bill
what's with the creepy voice
well
finally got my son to go to bed so I
don't want to wake him up all right
that's the deal
this obviously didn't happen during the
Steven Wright interview
my son goes to bed in normal hours all
right Simply Safe everybody you know
spring isn't Bloom what the is with
this Echo spring is In Bloom and you
know what comes out
next vacation season but before you pack
your bags be sure to secure your home
with SimpliSafe security
who is simply safe enjoy Peace of Mind
knowing your home is monitored Around
the Clock by trained agents you like
this soothing tone I'm doing ready to
act to defend against break-ins fires
and other threats
fast protect technology for Fast
Response monitoring agents to visually
verify the threat is real
and conveys eyewitness evidence to 9-1-1
dispatch for fast police or fire rescue
in control from anywhere anytime hey
with this stuff
this system with this top rated Simply
Safe app stay connected from anywhere
anytime arm or disarm your system
remotely check your cameras to make sure
everything is okay even unlock the front
door to let in a guest it has like some
Star Trek easy to set up or choose
when would he ever unlock the front door
to the spaceship Bill all right wrong
show you're right easy to set up or
choose Professional installation simply
not to be confused with the back door of
the spaceship Simply Safe ships to your
door and is easy for you to set up
yourself in about 30 minutes
or you know minus the Meltdown or have
simply saved certified technicians
install it to you a stall it for you I'd
go with that personally no reason to
wait with financing though through a
firm sorry secure your home today and
pay overtime in installments that fit
your budget customize the perfect system
for your home in just a few minutes at
simplysafe.com that's
s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-s-a-f-e.com uh go today
and claim your free indoor security
camera plus 20 off your order with
interacting interactive monitoring
that's simply safe
simplisafe.com
there's no safe like SimpliSafe alright
next up is stamps.com you know when
every person
uh moment and penny counts in your
business you can't afford to take any of
them for granted stamps.com gets it
because for the last 25 years they've
been helping businesses Like Yours save
time and money so you can focus on your
business knowing stamps.com has all the
postage needs covered with premium
discounts and great rates a post office
in your office with stamps.com all you
need is a computer a printer they even
send you a free scale so you'll have
everything you need to get started if
you need a package pickup you can easily
schedule it through your stamps.com
dashboard and if you sell products
online stamps.com seamlessly connects
with every major Marketplace and
shopping cart premium discounts all
right running a business isn't cheap
especially when it comes to help
fulfilling orders for customers luckily
stamps.com has a huge carrier discounts
up to 84 off all USPS and UPS rates
plusdamps.com automatically tells you
your cheapest and fastest shipping
options your postage partner for the
last 25 years for 25-year stamps.com has
been indispensable for over one million
businesses get to the United States post
office or the United Parcel Service
I'll get access to it the services you
need right from your computer anytime
day or night no biggie no lines no
traffic no waiting what are you waiting
for this stuff's great set your business
up for Success when you get started with
stamps.com today sign up with the promo
code burb urr for a special order that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale no
long-term contracts or commitments just
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the home page and select
Burr bur so
um the people you wanted to be with were
outside of the what was supposedly
you're supposed to be doing yeah like
the first time I hung out with a group
of people was just like yeah this is
where people I still remember I was on
my second gig ever I was at stitches and
I was at the open mic and it was the
first time I felt like I was around the
same kind of weird
like these guys are the same kind of
up that I am and I didn't have to
because I always had to like
you know because I hung out with
musicians I was playing drums and I was
trying to be that and I just always
would look to them to see what they were
doing to try to like and how I fit in
was I would make them laugh
um
both playing and joking I wasn't that
good a drummer but but like comedy was
the only thing I ever did where I didn't
feel like I had to look okay the people
that are doing like what are they doing
I mean I definitely learned from
watching people but it was the first
thing I think I ever did that I felt
like I could just sort of like start
walking
I didn't have to look like how do you
stand up doing this and then what do I
do you know did you found your like
Niche like yeah you're a thing yeah
there's two things when you went to
Emerson I went to Emerson the people who
wanted to go to Emerson that were
automatically the fact you wanted to go
there you weren't normal you were off
yeah so just just filling out
desire to go to the application that
already meant that you were a little bit
off so then you get it's an accidental
screening process so now you have all
these people who are off already and
they didn't even start yet and now all
your friends are weird in that yeah it's
sensuating now you're getting weirder
because you're feeding off and the same
thing with the comedians all those guys
at stitches you relate they all decided
like to do that because they're
Outsiders and describing the world what
the hell is this and all that so then
that you feel a connection I think that
don't you know feel a connection I was
like these guys don't have to get up in
the morning and go to work that's what I
was thinking then they come down here
they around they get a free beer I
was just like this is unbelievable like
this is illegal this is legal
this is legal like I just couldn't
believe that like
I could never get over the fact that if
you were a comedian and you didn't have
a day job that you get to get up when
you want to and my whole life up into
that point I had to get up when somebody
else told me to my parents come on it's
time for school I had a job I I whatever
the I was doing there was just oh
and and then for like two days a week
Saturday and Sunday like you got to feel
like what it felt like to have control
of your life and even then
you know my dad only needed like four I
would say come on get up I don't believe
in that thank you he didn't believe in
it he would just wake wake you
up like I also had like a paper route I
had a paper right up until like so I
always had to get up like on the
weekends the paper didn't have to be
there till eight in the morning so I
could actually get up at seven during
the week it was like six so when I
finally
didn't have like uh
a day job
and and I was hanging out with all of
these other people that didn't have day
jobs and it would be like a Tuesday and
they would be like hey man you want to
go see Dead Presidents or one of those
you know when I moved to New York like
95 or something I want to go see that
tomorrow like you know two o'clock show
yeah well let's go do that and and like
um I don't know I just feel like I I've
been
that comedy was the way to get out of
whatever the that other thing was
that I I did not
relate to
yeah there's this whole thing of what's
supposed to be happening what you're
supposed to be in and when you're
commuting all that you describe is like
you escaped it's like you got out of
some kind of not jail but you got out of
this thing and all the rules are
different all the requirements are
different and it's all because of our
imaginations have allowed us to
have a whole other thing of time when
you do this when you do that you know I
just feel very grateful that
but my this whole career my whole life
is because of making things up it's
unbelievable yeah it just it comes down
to your imagination and it's just like
so lucky it's just so lucky to be doing
all this and having a career of it like
it's it's it's fun it's playful right
making stuff up to me is like finger
painting with with words it's like kid
make believe not that it's not hard but
it's it's just a joy I also feel lucky
that people connected to the humor when
right in the beginning because if they
didn't I don't have another way of doing
it you know it was like they didn't like
that it's like oh well no I couldn't
like think of another way I always love
it you didn't even need a joke like you
would just wait you just you just walked
up and got a laugh
like they would be like screaming you
just go
thanks
[Laughter]
huge laugh and then also
they immediately knew who you were like
oh this guy's gonna be like super super
dry but before well I'm just gonna take
a major left turn here right turn
because I don't want to sit here and and
talk about Kami the whole time you're
also a huge Red Sox fan yeah which I am
um season has just started here and I I
got I always ask people this uh when did
you
what year did you go to the first time
you went to Fenway
let's see probably 455 probably 65 67.
Tony Conigliaro yeah yeah
Rico Petrocelli Jim longboard you know
Rico praticello used to live right up
the street from me when he was a little
kid while he was playing I yeah I lived
in uh I lived in Linfield it was right
towards the end of his career I think he
played until yeah Kenny Hodge lived down
the street one of the Bruins and Rico
Petrocelli
that must have been great to view your
mind to think they were right there I
mean I never saw him or anything but it
just like blew my mind and uh yeah and
everything was like it was weird
everything was so much smaller with just
like local TV and local sports but also
so any sort of celebrity was so friggin
huge but when I was really little I I
lived in like Peabody Linfield we
bounced around a little bit before I
ended up in Canton but um
he was yeah he was like right down the
street so George Scott's Cecil Cooper
maybe yeah
Jerry a deer that's one of my second
baseman one of my favorite like if I um
you know every year we go back to Boston
for a couple weeks and
um I always try to take in at least one
if not two games and it's one of my uh
because one of my my dreams when I was a
kid that's how my dreams were was I was
gonna live in Boston and I was going to
have season tickets to the Patriots the
Celtics the Red Sox and the Bruins and I
was going to go to somehow I was going
to have the money to do that and the
time
to go and I was going to go to all the
games
and
and it was funny you know what I when I
thought about it I didn't even think
about doing it with anybody else like in
my my mind it was just like
and then everybody was gonna think I was
awesome because I could do that like
that that was like everyone
always you know like whatever the
equation was it always equaled and then
everybody thought it was awesome so they
stopped with me
[Laughter]
that's great
yeah so I I often like when I take time
off I actually think of you sometimes
really because I'll be watching a game
and I go I bet Stevens whatever
the he lives is sitting right now
watching every single pitch he's not
recording it he's not fast forwarding
through the commercials he's just
sitting there watching the game I just
picture you alone like keeping score
I love keeping score I love keeping
score even no no no no no no I mean I
did it when I was 12 13 14. no if I go
to a game I won't keep score you really
I I have to fight not being that old guy
with the AM radio so you know like
exactly like what's what's uh do they
still sell the program to keep score in
it they sell it now they used to give it
to you yeah when you walk I think that's
how it's still in there people do yeah
no you can't so um actually I got uh
last year I got when the Red Sox came
down to Anaheim
to play a game down there they asked me
to come down because I had a show coming
up in Boston I had to promote so I went
down there and I and and I was keeping
score oh maybe that was when I was at
Fenway I can't remember but I went up
there and uh you know uke was up there
and everything and he keeps he's keeping
score because it's also if you're
announcing a game like it's it's a way
that you can be like yeah he's single to
left the last time but blah blah you
know you got like 18 hitters going
during a game I mean you can't really
remember like what happened uh to the
numbers eight or nine hitter
um so I kind of got a kick out of the
fact that they they keep score uh I
wasn't finally last Wednesday
of course you were how do you think of
that team the thing is I don't I don't
know not 85 percent of the names I don't
know
you know but but going if I wanted to go
half of go more than half of gone is
going into the place I think I wanted a
fix like a drug addict I wanted to be in
there I watched three Innings and then I
left because that was that was like that
was enough that was enough you know what
I missed I missed when it was like
mostly empty well it was empty oh I
forgot to tell you it was more than half
empty it was in the day it was 45
degrees oh yeah last week and there was
seats all around and it was like oh yeah
this is like before
2004. that's all great it's all
fantastic yeah but this other version
before is almost nostalgic it's like oh
you know dude we used to drive by it and
all of a sudden we'd there'd be a game
my dad like hey you want to go be like
yeah you just walk in you know yeah just
buy four or five tickets no problem you
know we'd always say like blue seats or
whatever but like the stadium was so
small they were always like uh they
always like great seats but um and you
did a show there right how did it feel
like you grow up as a Red Sox fan your
whole life and then you're in there
doing a show I mean how was that oh that
was uh well I mean it's obviously
nerve-wracking
but um once I realized you know I was
kind of walking around Boston leading up
to it it was during our vacation back
there and I just kept running into
people and they would just be like hey
man hey good luck it just they were
really nice and I kind of felt like the
city was behind me excellent and when I
got up there I took about you know 20
minutes and I realized oh this is just
going to be a show this is crazy and I
just kept looking I just kept seeing it
said you know I was like it's like I was
playing center field like left Center
and I was facing and I just kept looking
up and every once in a while I would
just say Fenway Park and I would think
the first time I ever went
we sat and the blue seats
in right field and there was like I
couldn't believe it I was like that's
Dwight Evans right there and I was so
hoping that a ball got in the corner and
somebody tried to stretch a double into
a triple so I could see that arm yeah
just watch it you know bounce all the
way probably to Butch Hopson was
probably playing third at the time so I
thought about that while you're on the
show you're thinking about that yeah
well you get a laughing kind of look
over him yeah like like
how to help would I ever tell the young
me
the Little Billy Burr that this is that
this was gonna happen all those things
that you talked about making fantasizing
up growing up and everything that's what
that's is you said some of them are real
that has to be a real I don't even know
if you ever thought of that but that's
as real that's as amazing as any fantasy
don't you think yeah you know what's
weird though is then when it happens do
you ever have that thing where you dream
about something you dream about
something and then then you actually do
it there's something about it that it
now it doesn't feel like it was real
or it doesn't mean as much like uh
um
like you dream about being in a movie
right yeah and it just feels like it's
this gigantic
thing like being in a movie and
then you get there and we're shooting in
a room like this there's just this
little camera crew and it's like you
know what is big is where how many
people can possibly see it but when
you're doing it it's this really little
thing like I remember
um
I was doing uh
I think I was doing Seth Meyer's show
and uh Michael O'Brien said to me he
goes uh hey you know the SNL's uh stage
is right next door you want to look at
it and like SNL's most intimidating
thing
ever to me so I was like yeah I would
love to go there maybe just stand on
that stage and kind of
do something to try to feel comfortable
and I walked in and I just like
and I saw like the bleachers and like
how small it is yeah this huge thing
like I remember first time I went to a
taping of Letterman
um I just started doing stand up and my
brother got me tickets for my birthday
and we drove down I was still living in
Boston and I went to it and I remember
thinking like Dave's desk is way over
there and Paul shaping way over there in
the middle and it was just this little
last stage and I I couldn't believe it
I'm like this big thing this giant thing
is just from there to there like it was
Unreal and um
even Fenway prayer yeah when you see
that it's much smaller than you had it
in your mind
uh yeah that was uh that was just beyond
that that was uh
um
yeah that never
that never quite made sense in my head
and it's funny I'm upset with my agent
and happy with him at the same time
because he booked me in Toronto
like two days later and so you know my
TR my tour Guy Kenny is always like you
know don't you know don't travel day of
God knows something can happen so I
literally did the gig smoked a cigar
with Tony V out in right field hung with
my family and everything had a great
time and all these friends and like oh
my God people I went to high school with
like it was a mini High School reunion
and I got to go which I yeah the only
thing that bumped me out was I didn't
get to stay there long because I really
I loved my grade and all the kids I went
to school with everyone was just a good
right and then
um
and like it just happened and it was
over and I was so relieved
and it was the same feeling I had after
SNL where I was just like that could not
have gone any better
you know even the little mistakes you
made who gives a it was just that
was awesome the pressure's gone and I
remember being like giddy
at Logan and then we landed in Toronto
and then it was just sort of back to the
Grind
and yeah I I saw the I kind of saw the
humor in it Rose just going like uh Hey
wasn't that amazing man I get back on
the horse you know yeah
extreme situation so everything's turned
way up and then then you're you know
going you're in line buying mints yeah
but I love that yeah and I actually feel
bad for people that that that have that
thing where they needed to keep going
because I always feel like oh man they
they have like stage five stand-up
comedian disease where I'm only I'm only
a stomach little he's like stage three
like like this guy's terminal like I
remember those guys I would do the role
with these guys will you do like two
shows you killed and all I
wanted was quiet let's go find a dive
bar whatever and they wanted to go to
like the dance club with the DJs playing
like all loud and get bottle service and
and I'm like I feel like I'm in a
Motley Crew video right now this
guy I I this is too much like I just
want to go uh go sit somewhere and chill
Road and I do several shows and then
it's over and then I wake up the next
day and I go to the airport when I go
into the airport and I know there's no
more shows no I mean I like doing the
show it's just very intense and I walk
in and it's like
oh just okay here's the ticket okay you
know waiting out okay I'll go over there
and look at some magazines because some
to make up for the intensity yeah it's
like a balancing thing no my my my my
favorite thing is is just
just sitting down doing nothing which it
took me forever it took me like say I
took 12 weeks off it took me 10 weeks to
figure out how to do that and then I
finally figured it out my
vacation was over
nothing is an incredible thing because
the word but in other word nothing has a
negative connotation you know nothing
but if you're doing nothing it's very
helpful because your mind
slowly starts to send up you know ideas
and everything so doing nothing is
almost it's almost like you know rather
than okay I gotta write more I gotta
write something else
do it I've read about I've read I've
read about doing nothing
it's it's true though I was saying that
to uh what's his name Jeff no what's his
name what um and Mike Jake Jake we I
don't know why it came up but that's
when I and I know that it's it's a good
thing I don't put it down like oh I'm
doing nothing I know I discovered a long
time ago that at least for creativity
that's where your mind can grow send you
something from the subconscious because
there's no pressure you're not
pressuring yourself you're just like
this I got a buddy of mine Paul Paul
verzi great comedian like he is great
about that like I remember when he came
out here to visit he was promoting
something and he had all of this stuff
and then we went over uh
another one of our buddies places and we
went over there and he goes hey he goes
because he'd just done a far chasing
finish he goes he goes guess what I have
for the rest of the day I said what he
goes nothing
I got nothing like I can just sit here
and do nothing and I remember
like I kind of had nothing but I still
had to go pick up my daughter and I was
like envious it's like this guy could
just sit here and do nothing on like a
Thursday for the rest of the day
and I forget what we were gonna do but
we just sat there like smoking cigars in
the afternoon on a Thursday and and I
just kept thinking like I was almost
like looking at him like this this guy
has no it's Thursday and he has nothing
to do that's amazing you said I
kind of had nothing yeah yeah that's
that's your world
I kind of had nothing I kind of had
nothing for like a couple hours but like
when you got kids you always you always
have something but if you sit in there
smoking cigars with that guy and you're
not even doing it that's an amazing it
appears to be nothing but your time with
him
doing nothing smoking that's as
heightened this that's a fantastic thing
yeah this is becoming like George Carlin
where something is actually nothing and
nothing is something
like everybody else's stuff is and
all your and stuff it's sort of in
that world because that's where it is
like I have stuff like I have something
to do which is it's usually at the end
of your life in your deathbed you look
back on it it equates it equates to
nothing and what I think I really on my
deathbed what I'm going to think about
other than my family and loved ones is
that time I said yeah with my buddy
smoking cigar on a Thursday all went to
go see the movies on on like a like a
Tuesday because uh
it's fun
and I think that's how I ended up
getting into this business was it was
just like I I so much of it was not fun
math was not fun read this book Because
I Said So not fun and I was just I just
I don't know I was like a cat on a leash
like this is awful I don't want
to do this so
um
okay I do have to ask
like how how did it take seven years to
write this and how did you allow
yourself without beating yourself up
that you still haven't finished it where
well I wrote a story for Rolling Stone
magazine 1986 it was a fantasy fairy
tale about how the beach was invented
you know
it's
dude you are just I would never need to
take if I just hung out with you there's
no reason to take mushrooms it's just
like just talking how like this is
something I never thought all right
okay well they was signed they gave out
they called 10 people and they said we
have some subjects by the time they
called me and there was only two left to
choose from the beach and another one I
don't even know what the other so I
chose the beach and I ended up writing
this thing about how it became bathing
suits and coolers and why the Lifeguard
chairs high up and all like in every few
years I would read it because I liked it
and I read it and then uh I thought I
should write I should write another
things I shouldn't so then I started
writing uh I was on Twitter actually
just briefly I got they got me this
Twitter thing and I was like I I don't
know I don't want to put jokes on there
I'm gonna start writing my next book on
Twitter so I was writing two sentences
at a time that of that yeah tweeting it
out yeah two sentences and then the next
day two sentence in the next and then
people were leaving messages saying
doesn't he know this is perfect for his
style of comment this is perfect for his
jokes right what's what is he doing and
other people oh my God he's writing a
novel on Twitter this is fantastic and
then I stopped writing it on then that
and I just just kept writing it but I
didn't have any no one was waiting for
it I didn't have a deal with the company
or anything I was just writing it and I
got into this Rhythm where I would try
to write like a little bit every day 200
words a day
and I then I really got in enjoying it
you see how it's another world like yeah
so I was in this other world but I
didn't have any pressure it's taken too
long what no one even knew I was doing
it man a couple of friends but so then
it was like
it's actually a really smart way to
create something I could never if they
someone said here's this amount of money
now give us the like the gears would
stop I could never write it on purpose
you know like now we paid you now come
up with it it was funny I'm doing
something next month this is a goof
something I'm gonna shoot
and because it's my own money there's no
deadline or anything and so I was like
well we can kind of maybe this would be
a long day I go why don't we shoot an
extra day why don't we just be human
beings and have an hour for lunch
we'll have a coffee truck why don't we
just actually have fun for four days and
shoot this thing and like everybody on
the zoom was just like oh my god I've
been waiting for a gig like this forever
it's funny like this this grind that
they do like there's never enough time
there's never enough money it's always
too late yeah one minute left and when
when we when I have a friend Dean Paris
so he's a director and he he uh we have
this term called the tree house that we
came up with and that term means when
you when you're creating like you're a
kid like you're 12 you're making up a
movie or something without that pressure
of Show Business the term tree house is
like it's just it's fun fun there's no
no one's waiting there's no rules you
know when you make a treehouse when
you're a kid or make stuff up there's
none of and that's kind of what you're
saying that sounds like that's a little
bit like that you're taking all that
stuff off the pressure off and you're
you're creating uh this environment
where it's a fun thing yeah because
that's that's the thing that I kept
running into is these things that I
dreamed about doing you end up doing on
me and they end up not being fun and I'm
like why isn't this fun I'm
around I'm doing all this stuff oh I
know why it isn't funny is because
people are telling me uh when the fun
ends
and how much money they have for the fun
and all of that type of stuff so it's
it's it's been shoved into this thing of
you know it's been monetized basically
and then the second is money involved
like all the fun goes away and and
that's what I just like I I you know the
things that I've worked on I've always
just going like why is there never
enough time
yeah it's like they always go ideally
this would be you know this amount of
time for this budget but we don't seem
to blah blah blah it's like what do you
it's like if I see one more
buy a 20 million dollar house knock it
down to then build another house like I
just like how does that dude not
immediately get audited it's like you
just spent 20 million on someone you
just somebody bought Betty White's house
10 million bucks and just knocked it
down whoa
and it's kind of like
like who the has the money to buy a
house and knock it down
like I'm gonna buy a car blow it up and
then build a car where that car just was
it's just like what the so
um
I I you know I do get on one side like
the business side of this where if they
didn't put the squeeze on us that that
you know we would sit there staring at
our navels too long and they would lose
their shirts to go out of business so
I'm trying to find the you know the the
happy medium like balance of that but
now you know maybe 55 in June you know
what I mean so I've I've at this point
uh
you know I just I just literally if it's
fun I'm gonna do it and I like helping
out the younger comics
and yeah I kind of like I've discovered
coffee oh my God yeah
yeah did you see the back of the book
The acknowledgments oh yeah the last
thing is coffee yeah I know and I
thought whenever you came
when I was talking about all the
different layers of this book
was I thought when you would start
talking you don't have to answer this
question either because I like not
knowing is that when you would start
talking about coffee because I knew this
kid wasn't drinking coffee I thought
that now I am in Steven's head writing
the book yes I wrote most I wrote that
book on coffee
you know I when I I coffee
uh hits me like a drug like cocaine
coffee makes my mind go crazy I have
this routine I write I'm a bike I ride a
bike so I would ride an hour in the
morning
and then I would go somewhere with a big
thermos and a half of coffee and I write
I I start drinking the coffee and my
mind
starts going like this and and I wrote
by the way I wrote the book on the my
phone did I tell you that no I wrote it
of course
why would you do anything normal
I wrote it in the notes section through
a telescope what while looking through a
telescope yes
because I could take I could never sit
in a room in a type burn or computer and
I need to move different locations in
the phone I could write it in anywhere I
wanted in the car on the beach anywhere
but but anyway I my mind would get
jazzed up on coffee and I knew I had
like a two hour window where where I
might I was just crazy
little Steven Wright did this coffee
affect you like that so I'm a ginger
dude we're weird with anesthetic and
coffee like I can literally drink like
back to back double espressos and then
take a nap but then every once in a
while I'll have a cappuccino and an
espresso and then I start getting like
all every once in a while it affects me
like regular people but most times it
kind of doesn't
um
okay we got uh unfortunately we're gonna
have to because
you're gonna have to start wrapping this
up but like I felt like when I was
reading this book
I was in the classroom
I saw on three planes I was in the
classroom I was going off into the
worlds in this kid's head
and then every once in a while you were
pulling me back and I was sitting I was
over your shoulder watching you writing
it really yeah when you would whenever
you would bring up coffee I'm like oh
now it's Steven
now we're back to Harold now we're in
the classroom now we're on the mushrooms
trip I'm in outer space
um you know I'm on this planet I'm in a
lighthouse I mean it's dude this thing
was a ride wow thank you so much
incredible
thank you dude I I think dude you're you
are seriously I don't say genius a lot
dude you are a Straight Up
Genius dude nobody thinks like you and I
am so happy to know you and and I'm so
glad that I had the privilege of reading
this book before anybody else it's
called Harold read this goddamn book man
it is it is it's a masterpiece
absolutely loved it thank you Bill and I
I also think you're amazing and you're
brilliant and I'm Blown Away by what you
do and how much you come up with I mean
not only is it a high level of the
volume is mind-blowing to me well you
know what else is is I said all that
nice about you just so you would do
that
no that means that means uh the world to
me because I have to say your whole all
you ding home guys if if you guys didn't
exist I wouldn't have a career you guys
like the I always the amount of times I
thought the luck I had
that you know my parents are Midwest
people and they ended up just you know
long story moved to Massachusetts and
what are the odds they moved to the
state that literally had the best comedy
scene and you guys
created it you know Leno you know had
the machete going through the strip
clubs and you guys started like you know
what what I love that your generation
started and has never ended is the the
marriage of Chinese food and stand-up
comedy is such a uniquely Massachusetts
New England type of thing like the like
dick Doherty rests the souls with those
ding hoes nothing oh sorry the uh the
Aku akus The Ding Ho I mean I play oh
yeah yeah like like part of doing
stand-up comedy for me when I started
was smelling Chinese food being cooked
but anyways dude I I thank you so much
for coming on this I hope this is this
is a huge success and I look forward to
the next one in 30 years or whenever you
write it thank you thanks for having me
on your show all right thank you very
much the one and only Steven Wright
thank you guys so much for watching
hey what's going on it's Bill Byrne it's
the Monday Morning podcast for Monday
May 11th uh 2015 what's going on uh yeah
um I'm out here in Boston
and I am four shows into my uh 19 Show
run here at the Wilbur Theater uh having
a good time so far running into a bunch
of people I went to high school with
worked with I had a I had a math teacher
from ninth grade
he showed up you know algebra no was it
algebra my algebra teacher
you know and I remember that year you
were supposed to get a uh
well you needed a 70. that's what
you needed you needed a 70 just
like my helicopter test he needed a 70.
to pass
in order to go on to Geometry more math
that I was never going to use in my life
because I was not going to be an
engineer
I had no idea what geometry was when I
took it nobody ever told me they just
you just showed up
and they just started you know you had
to memorize paragraphs about shapes
the Pythagorean theorem or some
like that right opposite angles are
congruent
remember all of that
remember if I don't even know if it's
like that for you youngsters out there
you youngsters
but the way that they go into math
and you can tell right now that I didn't
get the 70.
um
the way that they go into math
in high school
it's absolutely ridiculous because up
until then you know it's one plus one is
two two times two is four four divided
by two is two it's all numbers
right and then all of a sudden you get
to your freshman at least I did I got to
my freshman year I'm you know
sure if you're from Asia you got to this
in the fourth grade but I'm a white guy
I got to it in the ninth grade
okay
I got a regular old meat and
potatoes little stewed carrot
brain I can't help it all right my
ancestors boiled the food there was no
nutrients in it and as a result I'm five
years behind
an entire continent evidently
everything how great it is that we have
nuclear weapons so we can actually bully
people into actually thinking that we're
an intellectual Factor
you know what I mean
I mean seriously if we actually if the
world was like a SAT test we
really would not be doing well
oh yeah I'm dragging my whole country
down with my stupidity that's how
arrogant I am it can't just be
like hey Bill you ever think that maybe
you're a who should have
hit the books a little bit harder no no
I don't think that I think I think I'll
blame my whole country I'll blame the
whole school system that's what you do
right
that's what you do as a parent now when
you have a little kid who needs a
swift kick in his little Oshkosh but
gosh stupid oh aren't those
adorable overalls
oh the overalls are adorable that little
monster in them you know who's
never been told he's wrong his entire
life and that he's special right that
right there needs to pacifier
slapped out of his face I'm
sorry
losing my voice already hey I'm losing
my voice already you know I got another
20 shows to do
um
this would be a funny thing to say to
some parent
Excuse Me Miss if you don't get that kid
under control I'm gonna slap the
pacifier right out of his mouth
it's not illegal to say that that's
what's funny it's just not everybody has
like a cell phone camera and then they
would feel you like fill you film you
while you did it and then they would do
the provocative to try to get you to
watch the video
I was sitting on a park bench having a
great time with my toddler and I never
expected that or then and you won't
believe what happened next
then they would just cut to me hey lady
if you don't shut that kid up I'm gonna
slap the pacifier out of his mouth and
then everybody would come me right they
come at me
like I was the next Mussolini you know
never never once just going like hey
wait a minute the video kind of started
with him threatening that child you know
what I mean
threatening the mother uh you know to do
violence to the kid that's where
it started like what happened before
that
you know that's what they never they
never have that part in the video they
never had what happened before it's
always escalate it just starts with
somebody slapping a pacifier out of
somebody's mouth you know and admittedly
I watch those videos and I go hey come
on man you know at least wait till the
kids like four
right
but these videos it's always
starts like right there it's like what
happened right before then
you know
for all you know that's like a video
shoot
and the person is reading off like a
cute card oh you hear that hammering
I've been hearing that since seven in
the morning
yep there you go because I'm
staying with the beautiful mind right
now
add out the up the
goddamn trees you know it's one thing
that's funny if people really talk about
that
bang bang bang bang bang bang bang I've
been hearing that since seven in the
morning
you hear that
just laying here seven in the morning
and I'm
is over here bang bang bang bang right
and it's making me have all these
weird dreams I had this one
dream
you know
because that hammering that
Hammer egg
woke me up at seven in the morning my
first words
my first words today
were are you are you serious
that's how I woke up now you know it's
going to be a raw it's gonna be a rough
one when that's the first thing
and I just you know I was gonna wait
till the you know
you know the newspapers on the
deck were done and you know reading it
and trying to figure it out but I
figured you know that I'm just
gonna do the podcast while the hammer is
going on I got other to do
so I gotta deal with it means you gotta
deal with it
you get that one in oh good now he's got
to go cut another one so we got a nice
oh no
there it is
um
oh Jesus Christ
you times you gotta hit it
before it said
um
anyways so it was causing me to have all
these up dreams I had this
dream that me and Nia
split up
I didn't realize it in the dream I knew
I
I don't know when I was out drinking
with some other Comics who I don't even
know who they are in the dream and I
woke up the next day they're like dude
what you know what the happened to
you last night I was like what do you
mean what do you mean he's like you were
doing the chicken dance with that chick
and I was like I don't remember I
vaguely remember doing it and I was
embarrassed I don't know what the
chicken dance is either that's the weird
part about this dream and then all of a
sudden I was just in this relationship
with this woman who I didn't
want to be with and she had this weird
look on her face and she was walking
weird
she had like blonde hair she had a weird
look on her face and it was like she was
walking the whole thing I was
going what am I what did I do
I broke up with me and I got with this
and she's walking weird and we're doing
the chicken dance I want to get out of
here now all of that came from that
hammering I had that thing and
then I had another dream I was pulling
up to some department store in the hood
for some reason because I wanted
to shop
right and these guys going hey man why
don't you just park right here why don't
you park you know I parked in this spot
and then they came up they said oh this
this spot's for our church
why don't you go park down the street oh
we'll do it we'll park it for you I was
like dude I'm not giving you my keys and
the next thing you know one of them was
in the car
and I was outside the car my cake you
know give me the keys back right
so I go into this bam bam bam bam bam
bam bam
so then I go into the department
store
no Jesus Christ it's the same
nail that's what kills me
funny if I go down there and he's
banging his head against the wall
trying to get all the voices out of
there
um so I uh I go into the
department store and it's just this
shitty ass place and it's like washers
and dryers and stuff and then all of a
sudden like five of them come in
and they go uh hey you know
you know we got to move your car or
something like that but blah blah blah
you know give me the keys and I'll go
I'm not giving you the keys
and they go why I go because I'm not the
white guy from Def Jam like oh okay here
you go here's my keys go move
the car I'm not moving the car
then I saw this whole part of the store
that and I think oh you're not gonna buy
anything here and I go oh I got no this
store sucks and then they showed
where all the good clothes were I was
like oh this shows up this store
is actually good
I know it's a up dream but I got
hammering in my head it's just as I'm as
I'm Dreaming here so I ended up going
out and my car's gone I walked down the
street to where it is and they've
up the fender now I'm driving away
no I got in it and somebody came up with
a gun was trying to rob me
I remember I just said go yourself
and now I was walking away and there was
like this Asian cop
I swear to God with like the Baltimore
riots playing on a TV or something I
don't know why I had this dream right
I'm walking out
and this Asian cop I'm going you see
these guys when they're gonna they're
gonna shoot me and he said
something
he's eating like this fish sandwich and
he was just like yeah you know I can't
help you you know he had the
white shirt on you know
the police chief who's just like
yeah you know I can't help you and then
they were saying they were going to
follow me and I said I said that I
didn't give a
go yourself and then I was on
Sunset Boulevard and I drove home to a
different house
and then I woke up I woke up and I had a
fantasy about having ridiculous security
and I popped up on that GPS screen and
all their phones as they were
pulling up the street
and I just yelled at him with this Goats
Head On said I was in the Illuminati
and they got scared and they left
that's my morning that's what happens
when you wake up to hammering
I don't know what any of that means but
I got to tell you as up as the
second dream was the first one was
scarier
Jesus Christ
even in my dream why don't I just say
hey you know I'm sure you're a lovely
person to somebody else but not to me I
don't want to be in this anymore
all right
it is you and it's me it's that's my new
one instead it's not you it's me
it's not me it's you it is me and it's
you all right it's everybody
thanks to you it's not working for all
of us the ununited way
um so anyways
um
you know I mean think about this
add coming from a family
where everybody sort of has it a little
bit to different degrees you know what I
mean which just causes you to constantly
be going in like a different direction
every five seconds and all that type of
stuff I've actually made peace with it
and I don't think I don't think it's
really a big deal
when I just really sat down and I
thought about it you know is it trying
to put you on medication you my wife one
time I was just going like you know they
got stuff you know kind of takes the
edge off chills you out a little
bit
and I was like you want to hear
mind I'm not taking that stuff the
FDA doesn't even exist anymore
it's full of a bunch of people who used
to work for drug companies you got the
nuts running the Nut House I'm not
sticking anything in my body
other than aspirin
anything that wasn't made pre-1960s I'm
not sticking it in there unless I have a
terminal disease and at that point who
gives a I'll try anything
um
so
I actually had this conversation with
her I'd go do you ever think that having
add is actually natural
I mean I was born that way
you know for you to sit there and like
the way that they demonize that oh
people they have problems focusing and
they can't do well in school who gives a
I didn't do well in school I did
great in life though
you know what I mean the with the
schools in most jobs is what
they want you to do they want you to not
be thinking don't be going all
over the place anyway oh focus on this
job focus on what job this mind-numbing
horseshit that's not fulfilling
me on any goddamn level
stack of spreadsheets do you think I
laid in bed as a child and
that's what I thought about when I
dreamed someday oh someday what are you
gonna be Billy you're gonna be an
astronaut you want to play baseball no
no
I want I want a stack of spreadsheets
now here's the thing there's some people
that are into that and it gets
their juices going those are the people
who should be doing that job I gotta
admit with this pilot I had
no idea how much I was into reading
charts and graphing stuff and like the
temperature dew point and that whole
formula right subtract the temp
the dew point from the temperature
divide by 4.4 and then multiply by a
thousand I thought I'd hate that I
loved it
once I got it down I started getting the
right answers I really started thinking
about the genius of how somebody
actually came up with that got my
brain going and I loved it
you know what I mean which brings me
back to math in high school
right
math in high school how all of that
is unbelievable they're
basically beginning
to make you the math that you learn in
high school at least in my
country is they're making you like a
junior member of the Freemasons you know
you're starting to learn the secrets of
the universe with that math
now if they said that to start
it out you're not motivated I
would have been
this is this math that you're now going
to embark on that that we
taught you for the first eight years
okay that's just you know that's just
when you go down the street you buy a
loaf of bread you make sure they give
you the right amount of change okay now
this I should have been up there
wearing like some you know
secret society robe dimming the lights
with a flashlight under his chin right
just to kick it off
and just be like these
these formulas we about to show you
've shown like a video of like the
big bang in the solar system and
all that being made
The Mask you'll come to embark on
all the mysteries of the world up until
this point the Mysteries that we have
unraveled
the answers to all of these Mysteries
will now
be at your fingertips
they'll be in your mind
they are in your soul right I would have
aced that class
if you just walk in day one and
you write your name on the board and you
start throwing the alphabet in words and
with numbers you know
oh freckles in the back of the class I
just shut down I was like what the
is this
what is this I I don't get this I feel
stupid I know I'm gonna make the people
around me laugh so I needed a 70.
I needed a 70 to get through this
right and I ended up
getting
like a 68 and I was a douche to the
teacher all year bad move
bad move when I'm coming up there with
my lack of a hat in my freckled hands
and uh I had like the 68 a 69 I was
right there and he didn't give it to me
and uh and I went to summer school
and I was just like oh man this Summer's
gonna suck I had two weeks off and then
immediately I was back into uh
into summer school and then I got to
summer school and immediately it was the
best time I ever had in my life
because summer school is filled with a
bunch of class clowns
musicians artistic people people with
add and people who hate
Authority it was it was one of the great
classes
I had ever been in
they did this
I met you know I thought I was funny I
got to those classes I was I wasn't even
I kept my mouth shut I couldn't even
keep up with the level of funny that was
in those classes and uh and then
just the balls that the kids had
truly found kids that didn't give a
it's probably the bad crowd but you know
something if you
take what what you learn in that with
that attitude if you apply it to the
right areas of life
um it actually can work for you if you
apply it to the wrong areas you end up
in jail so you know you got to kind of
navigate those Waters
you know
if you know if your natural reaction to
somebody coming in going okay I can
settle down could I have your attention
please
if your natural reaction is is this
guy that's not exactly a bad thing
you know what I mean it's not actually a
good thing either you just got to know
when you got to know when to say
this guy oh who is this guy or why am I
listening to this guy I think you should
always think why am I listening to this
person unless you know you're on some
hike through the forest and you're with
some goddamn Ranger and there's a
grizzly bear and he turns around and be
like okay listen
this is really critical you know then
you listen you know be like
who the are you to tell me
dude I know it's a bear
um so anyways that add if
you have ADD don't let him put you on
medicine
I'm really going like is it Suzanne
Summers that got in trouble
it was one of those blondies it was the
chick from the MTV thing right she said
a bunch of stuff where she you know
didn't really do her homework uh what
was it on um um
autistic kids
all right always at Tom Cruise talking
about psychology I think I'm doing this
right now
you know what's that
is that the phone ringing oh Jesus
there's the phone phones ring and once
the hammering stops then the phone goes
2001 one one thousand two one thousand
three one thousand rings come on give me
four
over under I say six before it's picked
up
on five
is five
it comes a push ties lose ties lose
is six seven for the win come on seven
come on you seven
yeah
we got a winner
um
I'm gonna wait till this is done oh yeah
just
there's somebody downstairs sitting
right next to the phone too that's the
funny thing
anyways
um
yeah
that old add thing where it's
just like all right you gotta look you
gotta you know you need to calm down we
you know you need to focus maybe you're
you're a different kind of person you
don't need two years of a
language and go through all of that
Hammer Hammer Hammer Hammer Hammer
Hammer
Christ
unbelievable
unfucking believable constantly
places under construction I don't think
I've ever been here where it's not under
construction
It's A Beautiful Mind and it needs to be
occupied let me go build some
hello do you know me sure we all do I'm
that person hammering a at seven
in the morning how the do I get out
of this
sorry hold on a second close
and save close and discard
she's Apple products they always
got all these questions all right let's
read a couple of ads here for this week
all right so here we go back to the
Monday Morning podcast here
um
all right so when we La when you when I
I last talked to you when I checked in
on you on the Thursday afternoon Monday
Morning podcast just before Thursday
um by the way if you would like me to
read or rant about something
um talk about anything on the podcast
you'd like to try to get it on just
tweet me
um with the hashtag t a m m p basically
Thursday afternoon Monday Morning
podcast
Bank bank
oh God
oh my God anyways
if you'd like to do that
that's what you can do all right and
then
um
the else was I talking about where
the hell was I going with this oh yeah
on the Thursday afternoon podcast Monday
Morning podcast just before Thursday
um I was ranting about the Tom Brady
thing
which I cannot believe they're actually
gonna the the rumor is he's gonna get
suspended for two games for for Pure
speculation I love all you guys too that
show those text messages like this
damning information I can't tell what
they're talking about definitively and
neither can you all of this would be
laughed out of court but the thing is
this isn't a court it's a corporation
and what they really what corporations
really give a about is the opinion
of the base level mouth breathing
because that's the guy you
get the most money out of that's
the dope that shows up to the game
dressed wearing everything but helmets
and cleats goes down to the pro shop and
buys all the stuff and paints his
face
mom I'm the biggest fan
oh look at me I'm a fireman put me on
your shoulders even he woke up
even he woke up after a while and said
this is stupid it's not worth it
but those are the people those are the
same people that call in Sports Talk
Radio and all that the NFL is
gonna base maybe he could have probably
but we can't prove it report is they're
going to base the suspension on the
crowd's reaction
the base level mouth breathe and
so basically if you make enough
noise they're going to suspend this guy
for absolutely nothing
you know
I don't know if he knew I don't know if
he didn't know and that's to say
everybody can say the same thing but I
can tell you this what he what he did if
he even knew is is it's the
equivalent of he played with the
hockey stick with too big a curve on it
for about a period and a half and then
after that with the regulation stick
scored 50 goals but you're gonna
be like oh no now his whole career
and all that comes down to is you
hate the Patriots and you
hate the fact that they're
winning it's the dumbest ever and
I'll tell you this though but if this is
what you're gonna do if this is if this
is the standard that you want
okay I will go with it and you can call
Brady at cheater in the Patriots a
cheater but then we're gonna go through
the whole league and this is
just the that I know because I got
from some Steeler fan right
and I'm like really
well if we're just going to go on
circumstantial evidence uh you have a
sex offender at the QB person two-time
sex offender that we know of
at the QB position and also Terry
Bradshaw admitted to doing steroids
along with a bunch of other Steelers in
the 70s so you're no longer sixburg
you're two-time two two-time sex
offender two-time Super Bowl champion
Berg
you want that
what about Jerry Rice who admitted after
his career that he used to stick him
that wasn't quite legal
it wasn't legal so there you go
what did he win three titles with the
49ers those are out and the 49ers are
all cheaters you can go around the
League this this in the
league that you don't even
there's been no evidence you know why
there's no evidence is because the other
team that lost was never such a
like Jim irsay that they launched
an investigation
do you think that you can't do this to
every team on every game if you
looked under every jock strap
you wouldn't find something let's look
at the Dallas Cowboys in the early 90s
their head coach was Jimmy Johnson
Bang Bang
Jimmy Johnson from the University of
Miami okay basically a low
Security Federal prison that's
what their football program was when he
was running it then he goes to the
Dallas Cowboys AKA a Coke then slash
whorehouse of a franchise
their owner has a facelift his face is a
lie his face is cheating right out of
the gate the first thing you
you're telling me if you didn't look
under a couple of those cheerleaders
skirts you wouldn't have found something
give me a break I'll tell you
right if this guy gets suspended
this is an absolute goddamn
travesty that you're gonna do this tar
and feather one of the greatest
quarterbacks of all time and arguably
the greatest head coach of all time with
this
I I can't I
I don't even I think I won't watch
professional football I'm just going to
watch college football this year if this
is what happens
if because of a bunch of sore
losers and mouth breathing
morons complain enough
I swear to God I really think it's
because all that Ray Rice
you know what I mean now they didn't get
it right we got to get it right Ray Rice
knocks out his fiancee and the guy right
two two games two games suspension why
don't you cool it out there uh you know
uh you know come on man we can't have
this we can't you know they talk
to him like Henry Hill when he had his
gumar you know they came over come on
you got to go back to your wife okay we
can't have this this is ridiculous all
right come on you can't be staying over
here you got to go back to Karen that's
how they treated him right then all of a
sudden the video came out and they're
like oh wait a minute we uh we meant uh
we don't tolerate that and uh get out of
the league
get out of the league because we're so
pure right
it's all
it's all right and then
uh then what happens is goddamn fiancee
who should have left the guy
you know that's probably that's probably
grounds to be like you know this really
isn't what I'm looking for in a
relationship she goes but she forgives
the guy why does she forgive him
because he gave the apology of the
Universe because he makes a
zillion dollars a year
do you think if Ray Rice was working at
Midas Muffler the Forgiveness happens I
don't think it does
coming home every day smelling like
exhaust I don't think it does
it's all
that stupid pink that they're
making a zillion dollars off of you guys
go out and buy that those pink
jerseys and you think you're helping out
because your grandmother died of
breast cancer and you find like like one
half or one half or one percent
actually goes to the cause to raise
awareness not even to fight the disease
and the rest goes into these
owners Pockets do you see that
about the troops whenever they advertise
with the uh the flag and all
that you're thinking wow the NFL's
supporting the troops the military's got
to pay for that
you guys are talking about a hair
out of a ball
somebody said this weekend said if he
actually did it he should have just said
like yeah man I like that's what the
I like him at
gives me a little better feel you know
I didn't think it was that big a deal
and then you combine that with the fact
that ESPN did the study and showed it
was actually a disadvantage
and you combine it with the fact that
when he had the regulation ball
he scored he killed him even
worse
it's a Witch Hunt you Tower and
feather in this guy and you know what go
ahead and do it because that's
what sports fans do it's like New York
sports fans New York sports fans you
know all they bring up when they talk to
Boston fans are the two giant victories
over the Patriots so you couldn't beat
the Giants though couldn't they're still
bringing that up you know it's like
I don't even bring up the 04
Yankees do I do that
do I bring up uh you know oh the
Celtics got 17 championships do I
the only time I ever do that is
if a Knicks fan comes up to me and gives
me
New York fans sitting there
ignoring
hanging their hats on two wins
and ignoring the absolute
Carnage
the roadkill the sports roadkill of the
other eight teams
the other eight teams in your
State roadkill roadkill to the
point they shouldn't even be the in a
League
horrific absolutely horrific and
even your crown jewel the Yankees they
blew a three games to none leagues even
they got a big splooge of mud in
their face
unreal I'm real gotta
listen to Versi all week this
week talking about how telling Boston
fans how the Giants beat the
Patriots it's just like him
really are we still talking about the
whatever hey you know what good for you
good on you did you win two well we won
four well winning three World Series the
Stanley Cup in an NBA championship with
four teams I will take that I'll take
those two losses all day long
all day long but anyway so this past
Thursday so I was ragging about
this Brady as I just as I just did
and I don't want to hear anybody giving
me any about that I continue to
talk about this because you are
continuing to talk about it on the other
side Tower and Feathering my guy
so I'm gonna stick up for him here
um so anyways
other than the Brady thing last Thursday
the lightning were up three
games to none against the Canadians and
the capitals were up three games
to one against the New York Rangers and
all I was thinking was well at least
before that I was thinking all right
well if the Rangers and Canadians win
they play each other so they're gonna
knock one of them out so now I'm down to
just one
um
you know and then hopefully the ducks or
the Blackhawks will finish them off
right but all of a sudden it looked like
Tampa Bay was going to win and the
capitals were gonna win
you know and and they they were going to
get done away within the semis
oh that would have made me feel great
and then what happens Canadians win game
four all right then the Canadians they
got that Pride they got that
tradition you think you're gonna sweep
us go yourself all right come on
Tampa
finish them off in five they win
game five
well they have to game six right now so
game six is tonight
game six is tonight and I'm gonna tell
you right now Tampa
I swear to God eiserman's got to be down
there he's got to be down there he's got
to give him a speech because uh if they
lose this one it's over you can
never say it's over but it is
over
[Music]
and I actually think I think
I'm rooting for the capitals but I think
the Ranger series is over
I think it's over the
goddamn capitals man they just can't get
over the hump
you know you know what's funny was I
really agreed when they got rid of their
coach there I didn't think he
was the right guy
uh I can't remember his name because of
the B now he's with the Ducks I guess
guess I was wrong huh they're looking
like the favorites so anyways it's it's
actually gonna be uh
I think we're probably gonna be looking
at two game sevens
um you know as much as I root against
the Canadians in the Rangers
it's actually exciting to watch a team
come back like that and uh and then also
it's extra hockey
you know so it's kind of a win-win they
either dispose of them quickly
or I get to watch more playoff games you
know God knows I got the time it's a
Bruins fan God knows I got the
time
um
so anyways uh I'm in the middle of this
run here in Boston which is really a
amazing thing and I want to
thank everybody who's come out so far
I'm really not taking this uh
this week lately you know this means a
lot to me that all these shows were
added and everybody comes out and uh
and it's really cool that I basically I
started my career 23 years ago right
across the street
or actually right across the street now
is the W Hotel but it used to be an
empty parking lot
and uh you can actually see Nick's
comedy stop
it was great they had this they still
have the sign and it lights up it's just
blocked by the hotel now so you can't
see it they're actually down to
only two shows a week which kind of
makes me sad but I gotta tell you I'm
like one of the few guys I know that the
original place where I started
um actually uh
still exists and is doing comedy that's
pretty good 23 years in
and uh I tell you I did so much stand up
in this State you know it was
Mother's day yesterday happy Mother's
Day to all the mothers and uh took my
mom out to brunch and all that
and met some of my other relatives and
stuff we all met at this restaurant and
I went in there and I was just like
Jesus Christ I did stand up in this this
space it wasn't this restaurant but it
was something else
like 20 years ago and then the
place right next to it used to be like a
ground round or a spaghetti Freddy's or
something like that and I used to stand
up in the basement of that
um all these memories coming
back
um
you know great memories some sad you
know I always think about Patrice when I
come back here I used to always
I used to swing by uh
you know I'd go Blue Hill Ave and I
would turn he lived down on uh
where did they live on Siever Street in
West Roxbury
I used to go down there and I'd pick
them up
we drive over no did I used to pick him
no he used to go into the clubs and then
I'd meet him in at the clubs and at
night I'd give him a ride home
and uh so just thinking about all of
that and all the uh
I don't know man it's been it's been one
of those things and just a bunch of
people that I went to high school with
and uh have been showing up which is
always great you know and uh fortunately
I had a really you know some people you
know due to hated high school they're
hitting my grade I didn't I
loved High School I hated the academic
part but I came a really good cool grade
and fortunately everybody I've run into
is doing really well and they're happy
and what's really cool too is they seem
the exact same I ran into a couple kids
the other night not even kids now
we're mid 40s
and uh it's crazy everyone that I run
into for my grade it was just like you
know 25 27 years in some cases have gone
by you just pick up right where you left
off talking about hey you know they got
kids or whatever they're doing and then
you just start talking about all the
dumb that we did had a couple
buddies of mine um
coming last night and I'm not going to
name the name of the school but
uh
he was he had this I'll tell the quick
version of the story
all right it's the late 80s
Appetite for Destruction is just
catching on people are playing the
cassette tape we're at this
party two of my psycho friends one of
them's gone now rest his soul
they go to go upstairs you know to go to
a different party all right they both
leave 10 minutes later they come
back one of them had a flat top he had a
gash going like almost like
someone tried to part his hair by
splitting his scalp he's got this
four inch gash on top of his
head and the other guy's got a separated
shoulder and a fat lip and we're like
what the happened they're like oh
you know we just walked into this party
we said hey is this a party and they
just started beating us up right so this
mob
goes up the goddamn stairs
right
and uh we you know we're going up the
stairs all drunk and we hear the party
and the biggest psycho out of all of us
knocked on the door
and and the person in the side goes
hello and he goes hey excuse me is there
a party in here and the dude
opened the door and then it just
Bedlam I'll never forget the sound of
that because it was all hardwood floors
it was like
what appeared to be 20 on 20 everybody
throwing Haymakers and blah blah
blah blah long story short the
Smoke Clears
and I'm kind of looking over at the
people we were fighting and it's like
six guys and six women and there's a
board game that's all over the
place uh we went to the wrong party
[Laughter]
they were in there playing like risk or
something and then 20 drunks came in
just wasn't 20. it was like I don't know
it was like eight of us
and uh
I don't know the real party was upstairs
it was funny was the kids upstairs
they actually sued my friends because
what they said happened didn't really
happen so we were talking about
just all of those days
there's so many funny details of some of
my friends and I I don't want to share
them all with you because I'm afraid
someone else is going to steal it and
put it in a script because there's a
couple of details from these guys first
he's always like dude that's
hilarious
you got to put that in something but uh
so we were just talking about all those
old days and uh
oh my God this guy got mad at the other
guy and he threw a keg right through his
windshield
I got arrested for drinking and driving
because I was trying to get home to the
Patriots Rams game
that was when I got pulled over I
remember the cop pulled me over and he
said where you coming from and I said ah
Boston he goes Boston
you want to get out of the car please in
a fifth what a show I remember when
that was trying to put my finger
to my nose it from
8 to 12 went good as far as the arm
movement but when I went 12 to six it
felt like somebody else's hand just came
down and slapped me in the head
then he goes you want to turn around and
face the car and put your arms out and
try to stand at one he was just trying
to get me in the position he just
cuffed me
that was bad it was bad I blew a
one-night you know thought I had the two
thought I had the two all right let's do
a little more advertising here that's
good convicted drunk driver here
we go let's do some advertising here
and he's not even talking about the
dangers of it
all right Legal Zoom everyone
are you the next World Famous
entrepreneur or maybe you don't care
about Fame you just want to help people
whatever your motivation
if you're an innovator it's easy to
launch your dream this month with
LegalZoom incorporate or form an LLC to
start your business register your
trademark to protect your products and
services apply for a patent to secure
your invention or over the over the past
decade a legalism has helped more than a
million people just like you turn their
ideas into reality so what's special
about this month well for a limited time
you can get us you can get special
savings on any trademark copyright a
provisional patent application go to
legalism.com today to get started they
even can help you if you have a great
idea but you're not sure where to begin
since they're not a law law firm you can
get advice from legalzoom's network of
independent attorneys in Most states
that means you can get the guidance you
need to get your idea off of the ground
don't forget to enter Burr in the
referral box at checkout this month for
your special discount legalzoom.com
promo code Burr b-u-r-r legal help is
here all right stamps.com everyone uh
lastly but not least most of us are
trying to find more time every day get
every day to get things done so you
can't let trips to the post office slow
you down now now you don't have to
thanks to stamps.com with stamps.com you
can buy and print official U.S postage
right from your own computer and printer
stamps.com will send you a digital scale
audit that automatically calculates the
exact postage you need for any letter or
package any class of mail you'll never
waste valuable time going to the post
office again do everything right from
your desk with stamps.com print the
postage you need
uh put it on your letter or package and
then just hand it to your mail carrier
and you know what you're all done I use
stamps.com to send out all my posters
like the little one I'm selling
this week at the Wilbur
um autograph poster by the way if you're
coming down uh right now use my last
name Burr for this special offer no risk
trial plus 110 bonus offer that includes
the digital scale and up to 55 free
postage don't wait go to stamps.com
before you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type in Burr that's stamps.com enter
Burr all right mercifully
the reading out loud portion of the
program is over
um
oh for sakes what happened
I I you know something I absolutely
100 hate computers I had all my
questions what happened what does it
mean when you click on it oh there it is
there it is
I like I was just going to ask you that
like you could answer me on a recording
all right Fed Up hey Bill saw a great
documentary called fed up a few things
they talked about sounded like stuff you
met you'd mentioned on the podcast I was
wondering if you've seen it it focuses
on the dangers of sugar and the
addiction that most Americans have
definitely check it out if you haven't
um no I've read enough on red I haven't
read I mean read a little bit but I
mostly watched a bunch of documentaries
and uh I've pretty much found that
they're
they are
they're right on they're very accurate
but I tell you it's very difficult to
try to eat food now that has not been uh
tampered with on some level and uh I try
to be empathetic
to the people that grow the food
thinking like well you know if you gotta
feed
seven billion goddamn people or whatever
300 whatever there is in this country
though 300 something million 400 million
you know you get you're going to need
some pesticides
um
but um you know
I'm trying not to talk on my cell phone
anymore with it up to my head I don't go
through that airport security where they
use that you know x-ray light
thing that they're using I don't go
through that thing
um
I just I don't with any of that
stuff I try to avoid that as much as I
can while all the time drinking way too
much and occasionally smoking a cigar so
I'm the typical hypocrite where
in this room I I'm talking holier than
now and then in the other room I'm a
devil so I don't know I I
recommend that people watch that stuff
you just take what you can from it uh
maybe you think it's total and
you keep on eating Twix bars and
you know
whatever the else you want to eat
um you know have at it whatever it's
your body put in it whatever you want to
do but I'm not going to be that person
wagging your finger going we need to
stop these people they're poisoning
people you know I let somebody
else do that somebody else wants to
lead the March down the goddamn
road I'll I'll be there
well I I don't know I have no idea oh
God Andrew Jackson would slap me
in the face with this powdered wig all
right girl with no name
Hey Big Balls Billy I was in New Orleans
for jazz fest last weekend man and I met
an absolutely gorgeous girl wow that's
already a great story
went to a music festival and of one of
the great music cities probably the best
music City in the goddamn country
relax Nashville
um and you met a beautiful woman that's
awesome I like this already this is a
movie I'm watching first 10 pages I'm in
uh we immediately hit it off last
Saturday and had a phenomenal night
together in the French Quarter the next
day we get we exchanged numbers and said
our goodbyes as she lives in California
and I'm in Florida uh-oh this entire
this entire last week we've been texting
non-stop to each other and I'm beginning
to fall into the first stages of love
with this gal the problem is I did not
remember her name but she has used mine
repeatedly oh dude we both enjoyed
jobs where we have
where we travel quite a bit so we are
planning on having a George Clooney
slash
Vera
for Miga I don't know in up in the air
type relationship we were planning on
meeting up in New York on Memorial Day
week my problem is I don't know the best
way to figure out what her name is I
feel like straight up asking her name at
this point would make me come across as
a total douchebag and risk jeopardizing
the relationship dude that means at some
point in the French Quarter you've
already forgot her name
oh God oh my God this is making
me feel nervous also I am afraid that
continuing using pronouns as I have them
will get me in trouble sooner than later
when this happened in the past I would
just tell the girl to add me on Facebook
to get her name that way however I was
forced to delete my Facebook account in
my previous relationship a move I am
regretting more and more each day and
any help on a Suave way I can attain
this girl's name without coming across
as a chauvinistic wouldn't be
much appreciated as always go
yourself well there's nothing
chauvinistic about forgetting the name
um and why did you have to delete your
account
what happened hell that's no fury what
did you do did you do something
because I would just say well why don't
you just add your account back up again
this is what you should you already
talked about it on Facebook
just text her and say
oh no you can't say where's your account
should be it's under my name
um
this is what I would do
ah Jesus
I would add
this is this is what you do this
is what you do just create an account
under a different name like your
nickname or something stupid
you know and you can just say like ah
you know I just think sometimes these
social network things are a little
evasion like if you know an invasion of
privacy and just
oh man I don't know this is tricky
should be like well just add me it's
under my name do you know what my
name is
oh boy
um all right guys we're gonna need some
help on this one because I'm
failing miserably the only thing I can
think is get back on Facebook
um but when you get back on Facebook
she's gonna be like why don't you just
go over and add me
um
is she on Twitter
ask her what a Twitter handle is
there's got to be a way to do it through
social media
I really feel at this point that I don't
know that you can ask her what
her name is it's too long at
this point to ask her what her name is
and also to be honest with you the fact
that you had to delete your account
you know and you've done this before in
the past you sounded me like you're kind
of out there crushing it so I really
don't feel too too bad for you
um and also you probably just from a
couple of details in that whatever the
you did
um
I don't know dude
I mean who the did you date Glenn
Close in uh you know you got
cheese on your nose whatever the
movie's called
the attraction Fatal Attraction right
um
who's getting who dude you around
on the other girl and then she just was
saying you're a cheating piece of
that's what I'm guessing and then you
had to get off Facebook that's what I'm
guessing right so
you did that you a friend
dude this other girl what did you
do I want to know I wanna I want the
second
installment of this what did you do to
get kicked off of Facebook
no you had to take off your account
because of a previous relationship
huh
I can tell you right now dude I don't
know what the you did but you're
never going to be able to run for
political office until you address this
part of your life right now sir all
right but other than that I would try to
maybe somehow through oh Jesus
Christ how do you do it
it's gonna be drunk rummaging
through a purse when she goes in to use
the bathroom
oh God you know I I would judge you if I
had done all of that you know you know
all right best athletes Billy boy I
tried that boxing workout that you
talked about on the show uh run for
three minutes then rest for a minute
oh no run for three minutes I said skip
rope for three minutes and rest for a
minute for 12 rounds kick my ass thanks
for the tip uh in your opinion what
sport has the best all-around athletes
um
best all-around athletes
uh you know I don't know I think they're
all on me I'll tell you as far
as physical condition
um
hockey players are have you ever seen we
were talking about that Comics come home
I forget who said it I want to give it
the comic credit I can't remember what
it was but it wasn't me it was another
comic who said that it says you never
see a fat hockey player and it's
true
and if you've ever played the sport you
know why
um
you just don't you just it's one of
those Sports where it's just you're just
burning so much calories you have to be
in such unbelievable physical condition
that you uh what is that sound
um was that a bird
it was a bird outside making
this weird noise every time I inhaled I
thought I had a problem with my chest
no I hear that again what is that
is it the bed are you guys hearing it is
it in my head what am I losing my mind
um anyways the um
I don't know those UFC guys are
unbelievable boxes are unreal
I have no idea Jesus Christ what a
show that Pacquiao Mayweather
fight was huh everybody's flipping the
out about that thing
Percy's convinced it's fixed listen to
the versie effect this week
he sits there going like dude you can
see it like when Pacquiao puts his head
down I'm sitting there going well you
don't think he put his head down during
the press conference because everyone
was bitching that they they got
over on the fight and he was embarrassed
I don't think that automatically means
that that was fixed but hey I like a
conspiracy like anybody
so anyways
all right how the do I get out of
this let's just go on to the
next goddamn question I'll read this
thing I swear to God I think I'm making
that noise when I breathe in
all right in love with the lesbian oh
you romantic fool
um hey Bill saw your show in Memphis and
I just wanted to say you killed
it thank you I drove all the way from
Arkansas and was stoked to meet you and
get an autographed poster uh well thank
you anyways I just wanted to get your
take on my weird situation there's this
girl I've liked since I started grad
school and we've known each other for
four years she's fun intelligent kind
and in my eyes at least beautiful
Well why'd you have to
qualify it there thing is I found out
early on she didn't play for the team I
thought she didn't play for the team I
thought she did I was devastated soon
after that the woman she loved died
and she still case taking care of said
woman's kids from a previous
relationship since then I've moved away
I've tried a bunch of things to try and
get over you know the usual gym
bury yourself and work go after the
ladies
I visited her intermittently in the past
four years well that's not good for you
and I can't seem to stop caring for her
would love to hear what you would do if
you were in my situation thanks again
and go yourself
um I think you just have to deal with
the fact that you're in love with
someone that's not going to love you and
you need to move on and just keep doing
what you're doing keep going to the gym
bury yourself in your work I wouldn't
bury yourself and work who the
wants to work all the time but yeah
instead of going after other ladies why
don't you try to go find one that you
have something in common with all right
like if you were to make a list right
now somebody you were looking for to
spend the rest of your life with I don't
think being a lesbian would be on that
list because she's not going to get with
you unless uh I don't know she feels
like living a lie right
or at some point you know what I mean
she's gonna go get her hair done
um
uh what would I do I would have faith in
the fact that you're the right person is
going to come into your life uh I would
stop with the visits because that's just
you know that's like going back and
hitting the crack pipe you know you're
Charlie Brown trying to kick the
football again you land on your
back and you get back up and what are
you doing you know I would just uh
you know I think if you want to
meet somebody nice you have to start
living a nice life yourself you know
what I mean like what's funny is you
know you see these dance clubs
nobody meets their wife or husband in
there you know
roofie
Central you know everybody on
drugs and glow sticks I mean just got a
bunch of
you know either immature or damaged
people in there
you don't put a baby in that but you
don't accept somebody's goddamn
baby batter oh it's disgusting uh you
just yeah get the out of there okay
you don't meet your wife you know in
black light
I would um
I don't know there's a lot of stuff that
you can do in your 20s to actually meet
a great person that you never really
think of doing because you think you got
to go out you want to go out to bars you
want to do all that crazy get it
out of your system but if you
actually you know I don't know join like
some sort of league play sports or do
some volunteer work or something like
that you're gonna meet a great person
you know or a fun person
stay out of those stupid ass
clubs that every every mouth breather
goes to
you know the kind of people that are
going to get Brady a two-game suspension
for a here of a
unbelievable who the weighs the
balls
can you guys yeah just set aside your
hatred for the Patriots can you just set
us that aside and then just sit there
and it and on any level as a
man admit to what the level of
Crybaby horseshit that that is
unfucking believable I'm
believable
I'm trying to think of anybody that
throws a ball that doesn't doctor it
every pitcher does every
quarterback does they scuff them up they
do all kinds of to get them
where they like it little little
English on the goddamn ball they all
do it every goddamn one of them
he's got a ritual of how they
like their football
do you honestly think that the reason
why you didn't make it to the NFL was
because the ball wasn't fully inflated
okay the next time you play a pickup
game why don't you let a little bit of
air out of the ball and all of a sudden
it'll magically go everywhere where you
want it to go you'd be throwing
like Tom Brady
it doesn't even make any sense
Jesus Christ
oh my God
this will make you guys non-patriot fans
fun uh happy yeah I will never get over
this if they tar and feather him
over this and then I
want all of you who support it
rather than being on the
internet come out to my show or whatever
you don't have to go to the Shelf just
afterwards I really want you to look me
in the eye and present your argument as
to why
you really feel that that like
gave him an advantage I really want to
know why like what
advantage and you'd be going against an
impartial scientist because ESPN hired
the person and God knows ESPN is in the
game of sensationalism
they didn't want that guy to
come up with a study that said it wasn't
an advantage
um they wanted it to say it was an
advantage and you know why I know that
is because they're completely ignoring
the fact that they had that study done
on their own Network
oh I'll tell you it bugs me you know all
right dilemma
um your podcast
all right so here's a dilemma for you uh
would you rather spend a year in jail no
having to sleep in the same cell cell
with a gay fellow named Mandingo Jones
oh Jesus is that the most hackiest
thing ever
um
well I tell you I'd rather have a gay
cell mate than a angry straight
one that wants to
like the gay guy would be a little more
gentle you know he's been there before
he's got some technique gross all right
uh or would you rather become a piece of
Banker
dude that's not that's not a dilemma
I I become a banker then I'd be
a moth and I rat everybody out
even then I couldn't I couldn't
wrap people out I'd just be going like
guys
you know
remember that day remember David Spade's
bit when he used when he was imitating
Michael J fox in uh
uh come on let's not rape this girl in
Vietnam whatever the movie was
called
was that guys you know
what are we doing here Sarge like that's
what I would be that guy
I mean although there's a part of me
that would like to be sitting in on
those meetings just to hear what the
just to hear what they said
you know what I mean how they present do
they literally present it like let's do
something illegal or do they use other
words where everybody just realizes what
they're presenting is not exactly within
the boundaries
and a little gamemanship a little
gamesmanship and banking I wonder how
they feel it feel like it you know
although I got to tell you
um
2008 was definitely Spygate when it was
uh
you know
when it was you know whatever
the they did they when they
artificially over inflated the prices of
the house
this forty thousand dollar house is
worth 90 grand and you know what
you make nine dollars a month and you're
qualified for a loan
um anyways
I have a patriot anti-patriot fans you
want to give a for Spygate
I'll take that all day long they
shouldn't have done it it was it was
cheating they should not have done that
all right it's a League wide memo
telling everybody to stop doing it and
the Arrogant continued to do it
I think he was guilty of arrogance I
think he was actually cheating I think
he would have used something a little
smaller than some Giant news TV thing
standing right there in the
goddamn sideline but if you want to say
it's that then you know fine if you
guys want to act like your team
does not do stuff to get a competitive
Edge think about all the guys
who are barely in the NFL barely
in the NFL and if they
get cut they're going to go to bagging
goddamn groceries at a Gelson's
you know or even worse of Vons
there are roach Brothers right
or
or you know
they could maybe do a little something
maybe grab a jersey here maybe put a
little sticky stuff on the gloves a
little I'm not talking about roids here
not talking about reuts
all right
Brady got busted for doing steroids fine
yes you're cheating
all right
absolutely but if you're talking about
little a little uh
let's do a little this do a little of
that each play if you're gonna
call that cheating I mean you're
really gonna you're gonna you're
gonna kill everybody in the
league I would say that's what I would